now here's where I really want to get
into that this is the main story for me
from the Elizabeth Warren DNA situation
the question for me is not what is her
exact Native American ancestry it's
partially about Trump lying claiming
initially that he would donate a million
bucks if she has a DNA test that shows
she's Native American then he said he
never said it now he says he wants to
test her DNA himself for me the most
interesting sort of after effect of the
DNA story is that the Russian troll BOTS
have been activated hugely there is a
really well put together reddit post
that points out that the hashtag
Pocahontas Trump's nickname for
Elizabeth Warren as well as a whole
bunch of other terms as you can see on
screen like Native American DNA and
other terms were trending on Hamilton 68
which is a website that tracks Kremlin
propaganda as well as on a website
called the bot Sentinel which also
tracks troll BOTS and fake news accounts
Russian trolls are specifically posting
and reposting and linking to a fake news
article from true pundit which
straight-up claims that Elizabeth Warren
faked her native-american ancestry if
you look at the top posts on a
notoriously Russian troll riddled
subreddit called the underscore Donald
as of this morning eight of the eleven
top posts from the prior 24 hours were
related to Elizabeth Warren and if you
classify or sort of categorize the
comments and the positions that are
being espoused the ones that are getting
the most play on the Internet are number
one the average American has more Native
American DNA than Elizabeth Warren
number two Harvard had her listed as a
person of color and number three
anything less than 1% doesn't mean
anything so the question is why why
would Russian trolls and bots focus on
the Elizabeth Warren DNA story which is
a seemingly sort of transient and niche
story that's not going to have any major
coverage even a week from now or a few
days from now and the answer appears to
be that the answer appears to you I
would say when you ask yourself what is
the
objective of the Kremlin in all of this
right why is the Kremlin meddling in our
election using trump to their advantage
the whole point is to destabilize the
u.s. and to create or grow cracks in the
social fabric to distract to keep create
strife particularly among racial lines
the Elizabeth Warren DNA test results
themselves aren't the important thing
for the Kremlin narrative but filling
the internet with posts and fake news
articles about apparent obsession with
the story distract from stories like
Russian collusion Trump's taxes Trump
blowing up the trade deficit despite
claiming as terrorists would fix it and
the really important part is that it
draws out the racists remember that two
stories that activated the Russian troll
BOTS were the baltimore police unrest
and the Ferguson Missouri protests both
were highly racialized stories and this
is straight out of the Russian
geopolitical playbook the book
foundations of geopolitics by Alexander
Dugan specifically advises that in the
United States what Russia should do is
use its special services to fuel
instability and separatism and
specifically to promote quote
afro-american racists Russia should
according to the playbook from 1997
introduce geopolitical disorder into
internal American activity encourage
ethnic separatism and racial conflict
that's why the Russians love the DNA
story mentioning DNA at all brings out
the racists it's got an overlap as well
with the race and IQ crowd and in
general any story that helps split
people among racial or ethnic lines or
gets people thinking that way is good
for Russia and it fuels the exact kind
of instability that Russia wants and
additionally the Russians may already be
anticipating that Warren could be a
strong presidential candidate in 2020
so why not have the double benefit of
starting to litter the internet with
this type of stuff about her that is the
most interesting element for me about
the Elizabeth Warren DNA story which is
that it has become a favorite story in
instantly of the Russian trolls and the
Russian BOTS
send me your thoughts make sure that you
are following the show on instagram at
david pakman show follow me on instagram
at david pakman quick break back after
this today's program is sponsored in
part by Blink accom slash Pakman if
you've not already heard about blink
estates amazing it's an app for your
phone tablet or web browser and what
they do is they take nonfiction books
popular nonfiction critically acclaimed
nonfiction they condense the book into a
fifteen minute audio book you get all
the most important information and
insights from each book but you can soak
up the entire essence of the book in one
sitting I've listened to a ton of books
on blinkin recent one is a Robert Rice's
new book the common good also bunk by
Kevin Young useful in preparing me for
the pseudo-science miniseries that we're
producing and if you are a david pakman
show viewer or listener you can get a
seven day free trial by going to blink
is calm slash Pakman if you're watching
on YouTube use the link in the video
description
after the free trial if you like it you
can get the full access to thousands of
condensed audiobooks for about five
bucks a month that's be li NK is t.com
/pa ke ma n